mir ist es wichtig dass wir dieses
themas ist es so wichtige thema nicht
nur reduzieren auf strafverschärfung
sondern dass wir unsere verantwortung
den kindern gegenüber annehmen in bezug
auf prävention in bezug auf stärkung der
ermittlungsarbeit und auch in bezug auf
strafen die das unrecht der tat auch
abbilden und in dieser gesamtheit möchte
ich es sehen und so habe ich mich auch
geäußert so exklusiv hat sie das der
bild gesagt was sagen wir dazu beträgt
gerade mal eineinhalb natürlich es ist
wichtig auch dass auf landesebene und
für die enter viel passieren muss dass
wir als gesellschaft gefragt sind ich
bin aber schon sehr froh dass wir da
jetzt auch gesetze angehen denn ganz
klar ich möchte wenn jemand sich
kinderpornos ansieht muss das strafbar
für mich sein ich kann es nicht
nachvollziehen dass es nicht strafbar
aber ich kann bewährungsstrafen in
diesem fall nicht nachvollziehen
ich finde wenn wir da nicht er ging ich
kann nicht nachvollziehen dass dieser
mann von dem spielplatz immer noch frei
herumläuft und eine bedrohung für kinder
ist und da helfen uns ich direkt in der
prävention wahrscheinlich machen diese
menschen es dann trotzdem
ich möchte aber wenn sie so etwas machen
dass sie hart bestraft werden
aber ich finde ich finde dieses
überhaupt das diskutiert wird sollte man
eventuell jetzt so eine harte strafe
oder so ich bin da muss ich aber
wirklich komplett rigoros und sagt ich
bin komplett für die meldepflicht ich
will ich will es wissen denn so jemand
in meiner nachbarschaft und ich glaube
auch nicht das jahr der eventuell
längere gefängnisstrafen vielleicht
geldstrafen was auch immer dass das
irgendwie abschreckt bin ich der meinung
das wird nicht funktionieren muss in die
öffentlichkeit zerren man muss eine
meldepflicht festlegen und dann ist das
ding also höher geht es gar nicht in dem
moment was halten sie davon frau war
echt ne mail anhänge auf jeden fall dass
diejenigen die so was machen also die
aktiv dabei sind also wirklich extrem
harte strafen bekommen müssen und sie
müssen und ich glaube das ist dann schon
abschreckung wirklich auch angst haben
dass sie dabei erwischt werden weil ich
glaube dass ist der hauptgrund also das
ist schon etwas was viele leute auch
leichtfertig einmal selbst im normalen
und im internet damit umgehen lässt weil
sie offensichtlich davon ausgehen sie
werden überhaupt nicht erwischt
passiert nichts
[Musik]